So just because a trait has a frequency of zero, meaning it's not seen at
all. Doesn't mean that, that allele isn't
still in the gene pool just floating around.
>> Exactly and this brings us back to the concept of genetic diversity.
Remember from our pedigrees we learned that it's not a good idea to
keep genes within a family tree.
Because those recessive genes that cause recessive
traits, right, they need other recessive genes
to make those recessive traits show up.
And that's going to happen when the gene pool stays small.
>> That's why you need to reproduce with somebody outside
of your immediate family tree to have more options of genes.
>> Exactly, and random mating and human travel around the world
does a pretty good job at mixing and matching these various alleles.
>> Every once in a while a selection happens and survival
of the fit enough cuts out some of the weaker alleles.
>> This definitely happens, but there's a lot of allele frequency
changes from random selection events, too. take
these flies buzzing around as a good example.
>> [Splats]
>> case in point. before Lauren swatted the flies, the
was roughly 50% of one color versus another color. But
her hand indiscriminately killed a lot of the bugs and
now what's left over is 25% of one color and
75% of another.
>> Oops. It's okay. But this is a great example of how
it was a completely random event. The color of the bug had
no bearing on whether or not the bug died. She just indiscriminately
smacked. So the change in frequency is a result of random selection.